ja hallo ich bin hier immer leer und hat
vom isi der isi betreibt den
pfarrkirchen drei geschäfte easy wie hat
triftig dieser lockdown ja dann locker
untertypen ziemlich hart wie gesagt mit
drei geschäften stehen da und schon
langsam geht uns die geduld aus und die
hoffnung stirbt zuletzt aber wir haben
definitiv keine hoffnung mehr
wir wissen auch nicht mehr weiter also
ich verstehe das nicht dass die
gastronomie hier drunter leiden muss
weil das lka hat heute auch selber
gesagt dass die gaststätten nicht der
treiber von der pandemie sind und wie
gesagt wenn das so weiter geht dann sehe
ich schwarz für uns auf jeden fall ja
was mich am meisten ärgert wir werden
hier abgestempelt als die größten
kriminellen und ich verstehe den locker
und wenn dann noch mal richtig zu das
heißt da die dass die pendler am meisten
hier was eine schuld also dass die halte
es dazu beigetragen haben und bei uns
der regionalen eigentlich an der
gastronomie nicht und das ist was mich
so nervt uns geärgert und wir stehen
halt wirklich da und wir wissen auch
nicht mehr weiter ich glaube strich
sprich für die meisten gastronomen hier
schauen wir mal wie es weitergeht
ganz ehrlich hast du ein bisschen
hoffnung naja wenn es so weitergeht
ich habe ich keine hoffnung mehr also
wirklich es braucht sich keiner wundern
sehr viele leute dann wir für immer
zusperren müssen
und also wie gesagt es geht auch um die
psyche wir wissen nicht was morgen ist
was übermorgen ist jetzt zehn tage
lockdown und wer weiß was danach ist
also ganz ehrlich und wirklich die worte
kann sicherlich locker und trifft
wirklich viele pakete sehr hart mehr
nachrichten und breaking news nur bei
bet schau dich hier das nächste video an
und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren